[Music]
i feel obligated to weigh in on this a
little bit this is the termination
notice from our machinery who builds the
machinery a game engine so quite a while
ago i made a video on this
on the machinery just to see how it
would go and you know i'm not like a
game engine professional but i thought
i'd try to make a little series where i
basically reviewed lesser known game
engines
and this was one of the first ones i did
and i actually didn't do any more of
that series because i didn't think it
went well to be quite frank like the
series and me doing that but maybe it
would have maybe i should continue it's
not really the point but apparently i
was not
too favorable of our machinery in my
video
and i was just off the cuff being honest
whatever yeah i was actually hoping to
be helpful as to like this is what you
could do to make it better sort of thing
but i can't help but feel a little bit
responsible um for putting something out
there that was
maybe perceived negatively not that
anybody's complained if anything people
have said hey you were right and it
feels bad to be right like i didn't want
to shut it down that's not my intention
and not that it's my fault they who
knows i don't know i don't know the devs
i don't know their intention i have no
idea honestly i'm not the person you
should be listening to you should talk
to the devs and their team if you want
real answers but i'm going to go over
what they sent and what i know and just
kind of review it from the public eye i
guess you would say so this is the email
i got from them because apparently i did
sign up at some point thank you so much
for supporting the machinery
unfortunately we've reached a point
where it is no longer possible for us to
continue in the current direction for
section 14 of the end user license
agreement the development of the
machinery will cease all licenses are
terminated terminated as a 14 days after
the date of this notice you are
requested to delete your copies of the
machinery we
really appreciate you be par being part
of the our machinery community
we hope we have been helpful in some way
to meet uh to your development needs our
machinery
okay what's section 14 i i don't know i
have no idea what this is i don't have a
license
uh i probably have a copy of it on some
drive i i don't know i think i might
have deleted it i honestly have no idea
but it's not a drive that's currently in
my computer because my os as some of you
might know crashed a couple weeks ago so
i'm actually on a pretty fresh install i
kept my data disk but i don't think i
installed you know what actually let me
just check i'll dig in right now so
that's yeah i don't have a copy of it
it's the short answer unless it's on my
old drive that crashed which whatever
i'm going to throw that out it's
recycled at some point it doesn't work
doesn't matter so what do we do next
where do we go from here i guess i look
at my video and what i said or
no there's a second there's a second
email there's a second email do you guys
know about the second email it gets put
in spam uh hold on a second oh i'll show
you
okay here it is
the second email it's updated
u-e-u-l-a
this was five days ago okay i've
isolated it down
um
two days before the termination notice
this might actually be important they
updated their eula so i'm wondering did
they update something in there
specifically to be able to terminate two
days later i've i don't know
open link
so we're gonna go here and we're just
gonna have a little poke around where's
section 14 update to terms
we reserve the right at any time and our
sole discretion to modify or replace any
part of this ula
in any
applicable additional terms without
prior notice you may agree you agree
that we may inform you of any updated
ula
terms oh my gosh just legal stuff is not
my forte i don't want to read this
honestly all right let's get let's read
the last sentence upon the termination
of your license you must immediately
cease all use of service and content
destroy any copies of service content in
your possession custodial or control
including any source code or binaries
related to the content
[Music]
what's going on let me i'm going to do
some more digging and we're going to see
if we can find out more
alright so we head on over to their
front page and this is what we have
a uh
a front page first thing we've updated
our terms okay
but it looks like they still have the
same
front page
i don't see any notice of the
cancellation here it was just the email
so are they like publicly announcing it
all right so they're publicly announcing
it surely they would do so on their
twitter that's kind of the standard
place to announce public things these
days right well let's have a look we got
an april release
we got an april pre-recorded talk
end of april
nothing from may nothing from june
nothing from july i also don't have
anything from those months but i'm not
the front of a
public company of a game engine that
people i do have a game engine but
nobody uses it like literally nobody
there's you can't even get a light well
i guess you can technically get a
license if you uh support me at like the
corporate level and github but i haven't
really made that license yet i'll like
literally make it when someone signs up
so anyway i guess it's
i'm trying to make sure i'm not being a
total hypocrite by just covering this
because i don't know we're on the
internet and crazy things happen but the
point is
they haven't publicly announced this
this only privately went out right i
know some other youtubers covered it
i've watched the
uh games from scratch video i i don't
know i didn't get a a whole lot of new
info out of it was kind of stuff already
new i kind of want to see if their
discord has more info or getting into a
gray area okay well it doesn't matter
because they don't have a discord
anymore the invite is invalid and they
don't seem to be maintaining it as far
as i know or
well i i don't know maybe they just
went full private and don't allow
anybody in there i i don't know what's
going on like i feel like i feel like
i'm a little confused do you guys feel a
little confused like what's going on
doesn't okay i always ask this question
in my video so i'm not just trying to be
i don't know whatever it sounds like but
i always ask the question of does it
even matter
right that's just like
you know a life question when you're
doing something silly for the day and
you're getting upset or whatever you
gotta ask yourself does it even matter
right i'm not trying to be like does
your engine matter or not of course it
matters
it was in my opinion
somewhat of an important development
although
the problem was not necessarily them or
their tech i don't think i think the
more the problem was
it's a saturated market
and you can't just bust in and
make something better than unreal or
unity or godot in it in a short period
of time and if you do it's going to be a
lot of pain and a lot of perseverance to
get that good you know or at that level
not saying you should even go in the
same direction to them i'm just saying
that
when people go for a game engine
the choice is kind of obvious for them
and to pick something new
that might have a lot of
growing pains
is not necessarily ideal when you're
making a game idea is to get it done
quickly you don't want to be spending 20
years on a game i'm starting to learn
this very quickly as i'm developing my
own and trying to make an engine and
it's
taking longer than i would have thought
you don't want to don't want to be in
the weeds for so long you just kind of
want to get it done get it released and
move on you don't you know it always
comes back to this i don't know i'm
going to make up a theory all right the
infinite life theory sometimes when
you're in a project and working on
something
you don't realize day to day that you
have a limited lifespan you feel like
i'm going to be able to work on this
until it's done and the thing is no you
won't
you'll be able to work on it until you
can get it as good as you can manage to
get it
you you won't be able to get it done and
it's like that for games too so you want
to get in there and get it as good as
you can get it get it as quickly as
possible
not necessarily take forever all right
well that's a whole nother side ramp but
i'm just the point is
it's very hard to get into
the game engine industry and have an
effect and i only name the top three
engines there's a lot of other really
good ones like there's what source
from valve now source 2 which you can
get i've played around with a little bit
all right i'm going to look at the devs
a little bit see if there's any answers
from them see if i can find any more
data on the machinery and we're going to
call this a video
okay i don't mean to like
uh call anyone out or anything but this
guy was just mentioned at the top of
their tweets and i think he works on a
little bit uh co-founder at our
machinery from stockholm okay cool
uh let's just see if he's got any info
about the engine
well he's got something in may
our machinery didn't have something well
okay
there's the one from our machinery so we
got a little bit of additional data here
what is this
okay so
hey we'll take you off our email list
just give us a couple weeks this is
nothing to do with our machinery this is
just his tweets but i'm curious what's
going on here there's somehow got to be
some info out there right just some
complaint about
email lists and taking forever calming
practice of using dlls by linking with a
companion static lab is unfortunate you
get all the drawbacks of both sides both
static and dynamic linking
we could dig into that but i have to
investigate actually yeah i always
thought that was weird too if you have a
dll there's usually a company static
live but
the static live is usually small because
it's all put in the dll instead the
shared one
so why do they still need a static live
i don't know there's some reason but
all the data should be in the dll so the
one that's being shared the dll multiple
programs use the dll
hopefully you guys know this if not i
talk about libraries a lot on my channel
so
you can probably find videos talking
about more but i know more about it now
than i did back then anyway
uh static life should be small but yeah
it's true but that doesn't have anything
to do with our machinery other than he
was you know tweaking the
lives and kind of notice that annoyance
dll plus header is an under appreciated
c library distribution mechanism yeah
that's how it typically is usually you
don't have a static life gets rid of
stag linking issues this
having the sources great building
resources often unfortunately not
trivial i don't know just kind of
various
complaints i don't really fully agree
like static linking is not an issue
the issue is you just need to link it
like
it's it's not an issue
that's all i want to say like yeah you
got a link to debug or release and get
things to line up properly but
it's not like you link it and it just
doesn't work well it does if you link to
the wrong debug release or can but yeah
you just have to have that sorted out
i would call it an issue i'll just call
it more of a complication which isn't
much better right all right i usually
don't tweet about project politics this
was june 24th but can't avoid it on a
day like this oh this was the the day of
well you know i'm not going to talk
about it on my channel i don't get into
the sort of stuff what horribly sad
devastating news
stacked court stripping women of their
right to bodily autonomy when an
absolute travesty let's remove everyone
involved from their position of power
his words not mine i'm just reading i
don't get involved and stuff but that
was his last tweet nothing to do with
our machinery just a little bit of
outrage about stuff
okay so
i don't want to speak too soon but i'm
seeing
a little notice of maybe internal
frustrations
uh that aren't public so i don't really
know but that's just the impression i
get
i wish all these dabs left they're
clearly very talented keep coding as i
always say on my channel
um
i don't know i'm gonna dig around a
little more before i make an outro
because i feel like there's more of this
all right just an article from well you
can see the address here probably
game industry.biz
by james batch
eller
that's bachelor spelled
like a coder would spell it if he didn't
know any better
um
well he
okay so he mentions there's no ask to
delete project you're only supposed to
delete the binaries
and source code not your projects
necessarily
so i guess that's
good
i didn't really understand that earlier
but there's not really much additional
info here
twitter page with silent yeah i saw that
we saw that
but yeah they've only been in
development for a year they plan to take
on unity and unreal no longer possible
for us to continue we don't know why
it's no longer possible for them to
continue that's the thing
we don't know if it's
internal differences lack of funding
uh just going in a different direction
just you know
just don't want to do it anymore you
know there's a lot of like fine reasons
like you know my heart's not anymore i'm
going to do something else and that
that's it
that's that's fine but we don't know we
just have no idea that's kind of the
problem
um that i think a lot of people are
sort of annoyed by now i suppose it's
only right if we cover what else we find
but i'm feeling a little sketchy at this
point i don't like to bring people into
the public eye that don't want to be
necessarily but we should probably
look at some more info because we know
who the other people are because like
sure nicholas is a co-founder but
that means there's other people involved
and i found uh that the one of the
founders is trisha gray she has a
linkedin profile but linkedin i don't
want it to track me and stuff so i'm not
signing into leaked in to look at her
linkedin you want to look at her
linkedin you can
but it's like you have to make an
account so
she's going to get a little ping that
you looked at or all this stuff and i
don't want i think overall linkedin is
good for people trying to find jobs
that's all i'll say i don't necessarily
have a problem with it i just don't like
all the pings and stuff but that's more
of a personal preference myself
so if you don't mind that i guess it's
fine all right well there's an online
education
article someone uh interviewing trisha
gray because it's it's a woman
breaking barriers article so
obviously a lot of politicalness
involved in all this like
i don't want to like get into that angle
really but here's the reality
of this uh
all this talk of women's rights and
stuff and game engines is basically that
it's not really involved it's
anyone can get as good as they want at
this stop just based on what they want
to do has nothing to do with male or
female or
well
it's a science thing all right you know
the way computers work is very sciencey
and when you're manipulating data and
bits and running software you're working
with pure math basically so
none of this political drama
helps at all it if anything it distracts
the mind from what is actually important
in making good technology now i know
that's like a hot take but
that's
objectively true i'm not saying the
other stuff isn't important it's just
it's more of a distraction than it is a
help when it comes to actually making
the tech the reality is you could have
the best or worse to be a male or a
female and it really doesn't matter what
matters is what's actually to work
i don't know how to say that i feel like
that's going to get twisted out of
context no matter how i say it but
that's all i'm going to say
all right well it looks like they were
just buddies they were they were having
beers at some
thing and they're all gamers and stuff
our client that i okay that i had was
okay so they were a client of of
trisha's and they decided hey well let's
make a company make a game company
change the world so they did they made
it they made our machinery and they
tried to change the world i think that's
kind of a humble beginning we still
don't know why they stopped
i'm guessing it was just not profitable
and maybe there was some
lack of drive behind the engine only one
person or two people working on it they
probably needed to hire more people
that's i'm just guessing that's what i'm
that's my feeling that i'm getting from
this so far let's see if we can find
anything about tobias tobias on twitter
that makes it a lot easier buffer lover
co-founder of our machinery rendering
architect cool
so he's this guy's an actual programmer
probably pretty good
i don't know that directly but our
machinery talk
this is from way earlier
i haven't really said much since
just uh
a blog post
taxonomy of bugs yeah
this is see this is the
the gritty stuff
so that's sort of interesting oh it's no
longer up
well that's unfortunate but no mention
of uh
anything else just that those three
decided to make a company and
a year later they've decided not to
we'd still like to know why guys like
other than you can't continue like
should we be worried about you guys you
know you're real people
and we wonder
now that the
you know okay here's the thing
when you make
a company and say we're gonna change the
world and then you like push it and push
it for a year
it's gonna get some traction whether you
like it or not and then if
it all comes crashing down people are
gonna wanna know the story of how it
came crashing down because people love
that kind of stuff they eat it up
all right well that's my take on the our
machinery shut down going a little
deeper hope you enjoyed hit the like
button if you did consider subscribing
and uh supporting me if you want to keep
seeing content about code here on code
tech editorials matt out peace